[Musique]
sacha filipenko bonsoir
bonsoir humour souvent pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle singer view nous
sommes en direct est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succinctement
les peines si on croit l'équipe et dia
j'ai 37 ans ou 38 je n'arrête pas de
confondre je suis un écrivain je suis
née à minsk à l'époque je travaillais
comme auteur de scénarios et comme
journaliste à la chaîne indépendante au
gt1 réussi mais je crois que la chose la
plus importante que j'ai fait dans ma
vie c'est d'avoir écrit donc à plusieurs
romans dont je suis fier et qui sont
traduits en plusieurs langues je suis
très content de les voir traduit en
français
vous reçoit ce soir parce que on a
besoin d'information n'a besoin de votre
prisme de lecture sur ce qui se passe en
ce moment ont dû créer non biélorussie
en russie on voudrait votre perception
de la situation première question je
vais vous poser parlez moi de votre
famille vos parents est-ce qu'ils ont
une perception des choses comment ça se
passe en fait
il ya deux mois j'étais petit je me
presse ne sera pas on pourra pas et
donner une réponse simple c'est une
question assez difficile parce que mes
relations avec mes parents ne sont pas
très simple on peut dire que c'était
plutôt ma grand mère qui m'a élevé que
mes parents et j'ai quitté ma maison à
cette eau est
en fait j'ai des parents très bien mais
il s'est fait que je crois que mon père
il n'a pas pu supporter certains
épreuves de sa vie il a éprouvé sur donc
à sur lui tout ce qui s'est passé avec
donc aller l'union soviétique il avait
donc il avait été
donc
simple personne et ensuite il est devenu
une personne assez riche assez influente
et je crois qu'il n'a pas su traverser
cette épreuve par la gloire et à un
moment il ya eu dans sa vie un peu plus
d'alcool qu'il faudrait en avoir dans la
vie d'une personne et c'est pour cela
que nous avons des relations assez
difficile et dans mon livre j'écris
aussi sur mes parents
aujourd'hui je pense que mes parents
malgré une relation qui reste un peu
difficiles sont fiers de moi et
malheureusement aujourd'hui mes parents
donc pâti c'est à cause de moi parce que
les enquêteurs qui viennent dans mon
appartement d'un autre appartement en
biélorussie il parle à mes parents et
c'est un inter qu'il dise que je dois
arrêter d'écrire des articles parce
qu'ils ne peuvent pas m'attraper mais
ils peuvent donc avoir mon père qui ne
devrait pas répondre de moi et avec
lequel mes relations auraient pu être
meilleurs
pourquoi il ya la police qui va chez
vous pourquoi ils la police qui fait
pression sur vos fonds
quant à mon style change écrit jamais
attaqué des notes des articles parce que
je suis publiées dans toute la presse
européenne donc dans le monde gardien ne
stoppe pas j'écris ce que le pouvoir
bien le russe a même pas lire j'ai écrit
par exemple une lettre ouverte à rené
fasel
le président de la ligue de la
fédération de hockey qui donc finalement
a mené à l'annulation de la coupe du
monde de hockey et un biélorusse y voilà
et donc j'ai écrit aussi sur un atelier
cherche sur les conditions donc de de
son emprisonnement et et comme elle est
citoyenne de suisse et il ya eu donc
l'ambassadeur suisse qui est venu dans
la prison donc et avec mon article en
demandant si tout était vrai je crois
que donc elle le pouvoir à un
biélorussie n'est pas très content parce
que j'écris
la biélorussie c'est la dernière
dictature d'europe
[Musique]
comment les biélorusses ce centre qu'est
ce qu'ils entreprennent s qui sont
content pas content d'avoir le grand
frère lourd russe juste à côté qui peut
mettre ses doigts dans le pays quand il
veut est ce qu'il ya des les
anticipations de révolution est ce qu'il
ya des stratégies pour se protéger du
pouvoir en place
watch and the race of champions il
faudra d'abord je voudrais commencer par
dire que ne sont pas la dernière
dictature
maintenant là
le cash enhco le second est là donc la
dernière dictature a déménagé en réussit
à nous étions à l'époque la dernière
victoire de l'europe mais aujourd'hui il
semble que nous ne le sont plus et alors
le cacher qu il s'est changé les choses
tantôt et le dernier dictateur tantôt je
n'ai plus le dernier et bien sûr que
tout au long de notre histoire nous
avons souffert de l'intervention de
russie dans nos affaires et du fait que
la russie ne ne considère pas comme un
peuple à part il croit que la
biélorussie c'est une partie de russie
et bien sûr qu'en
2020 nous sommes allés manifester
nous protestions non seulement contre le
cash enhco et la police et l'armée qui
lui ont prêté allégeance mais surtout un
2020 nous avons combattu contre la
russie qui soutenaient ben loukachenko
et contre poutine que je soutenais le
cash and co et dans ce sens là il arrive
que je suis parfois vous n'avez pas de
chance avec vos voisins mais quand vous
êtes un pays vous n'avez pas la
possibilité de déménager donc il faut
faire il faut il faut faire avec les
oisiens que vous avez comment ça se
passe la surveillance en biélorussie
c'est une surveillance électronique
c'est une surveillance à l'ancienne avec
des gens qui vous suivent est ce qu'il
ya des délations est ce qu'il ya des
gens rémunérés par l'état comme
des grands mères qui peuvent regarder
partout tout le temps comment ça se
passe
iam à gorazdevac top 14 kapan immense
les dix ans donc elle parlait que de la
surveillance
je peux vous raconter seulement les
exemples j'ai vraiment compris que
j'étais surveillé un jour donc
écrit un article en russie je quittais
minsk pour moscou par en train de nuit
et j'ai été dans un dans une voiture
totalement vide où il n'y avait
pas un chat et il y avait seulement dans
mon compartiment ans gars très baraqué
apparemment très fort qui est tenait
donc étonné l'article du journal avec
l'article et
son doigt était placé sur ma photo et
l'a fait l'air de lire cet article est
un et finalement elle m'a dit il faut
quand même être plus prudent de ce que
tu écris ça c'était le premier exemple
est le deuxième exemple un jour je suis
arrivée à minsk donc je suis arrivé à 9h
et à 9h06 je suis entré dans un café il
y a eu une femme qui s'est assise à ma
table qui a dit je suis votre fan vous
êtes quand est ce que vous êtes arrivé
quand est ce que vous allez repartir et
elle m'a posé énormément de questions
dont on voyait que elle ne s'intéressait
pas du tout à ce que j'écrivais mais
plutôt à ce que j'allais faire pendant
plusieurs jours et il ya encore un
troisième exemple le grand jeu au moment
où je parlais à la une réalisatrice
suisse qui voulait faire un film d'après
mon livre
quand nous avons parlé
elle m'a dit à ce que notre conversation
s'est faite en boucle et elle a fini par
répéter encore une fois notre
conversation téléphonique dans son
téléphone donc la c rie ans voilà et
c'est se fait différemment c'est très
différent là j'ai pu citer trois
exemples mais je crois qu'il ya beaucoup
plus de surveillance d'ims ma vie parce
que la bonne surveillance c'est celle
qu'on ne remarque pas là les trois cas
c'est soit quand c'est moi qui ai donc
qu'il est remarqué soit quand peut-être
on a essayé de me faire comprendre que
j'étais surveillée quand on a essayé de
vous faire comprendre que vous étiez
surveiller ils se sont rapprochés de
vous c'est à dire qu'ils ont atteint la
dernière limite
comment savoir une interaction physique
avec celui qui vous surveille c'est que
c'est déjà trop tard est-ce que vous
utiliser des techniques par exemple sur
vos communications numériques est ce que
vous avez fait auditer votre téléphone
portable pour savoir s'ils avaient des
des software pour vous écouter est ce
que vous avez fait la même chose sur
votre ordinateur portable est-ce que
vous utilisez par exemple machine à
écrire au lieu d'un ordinateur portable
pour écrire pour éviter d'être
surveillés est-ce que la conduite
introspective que la surveillance génère
chez vous ne vous met pas dans une
prison et est ce que c'est pas
l'objectif voulu de la surveillance
non je ne crois que de toute façon je
n'ai rien à cacher je suis un gars qui
écrit des livres qui écrit des blagues
pour les télés qui donc à nîmes une
chaîne instagram drôle j'ai strictement
rien à cacher je n'ai mène aucune
activité politique je ne suis pas un
politicien je suis pas un agent
donc jusqu'aujourd'hui je garde toujours
un mais le russe à l'adresse russe et on
ne dit que donc il faut changer il faut
changer le courriel parce que donc mes
courriels continue à être lus voilà et
pour moi je me dis c'est bien que
quelqu'un liz may mais mes courriels et
sait bien que si quelqu'un écoute mes
conversations téléphoniques parce que
tout d'abord il écoute d histoire drôle
et sympa et ça les cultivent un peu de
m'écouter et donc là j'ai strictement
rien à cacher et j'espère qu'ils vont
continuer à écouter mais je ne suis je
ne crois pas que je suis tellement
intéressant être sur lui et je crois
qu'en biélorussie chacun et surveiller
un dégré un autre est-ce que vous avez
vu le film qui s'appelle la vie des
autres
ranieri n'a bien sûr qu'est ce que ça
vous a
procuré qu'est ce que ça vous a pu
ressentir ce film
non qui a capturé quatre
autres avaient beaucoup dans les
archives une personne qui comprend très
bien ce qui s'est passé dans l'union
soviétique et comprend un petit peu
aussi ce qui se passait en allemagne
avec stasi avec la stasi jeu ce film n'a
peut-être pas surpris du point de vue
des informations qu'il donne de ce film
je retenue
deux blagues et en fait quand on regarde
un jeu les films on se dit toujours
c'est tellement dommage que c'est pas
moi qui ai écrit son scénario
le fait de voir
le musicien
surveiller quelqu'un de culture c'est un
peu ce qui vous arrive non
il ya dix noeuds ne sais pas c'est
difficile de le dire peut-être je vais
je vais dire que je suis surveillé et
ils ont déjà arrêté de me surveiller
parce qu'ils avaient ils ont compris que
j'étais parti et ce n'était plus
nécessaire
parce que je sais que si jamais je
j'essaie de passer la frontière
biélorusse je serais arrêté locaux et
dans dans la presse biélorusse
aujourd'hui n'arrête de paraître des
textes c'est assez ridicule de textes
caf clients sur moi et par exemple sur
la une de linge l'un des journaux on
disait que la société biélorusse se
demande s'il faut donc déchoir de
nationalité sacha filipenko et je me
suis imaginé ces gens là les gens de
tous les gens lambda qui après avoir
travaillé donc se mettre dans leur
cuisine et au lieu de regarder le foot
ils commencent à demander si sacha
filipenko doit être déchu de nationalité
je ne crois pas que je suis
particulièrement intéressant services
spéciaux je suis peut-être aussi
intéressants que d'autres donc personne
qui parle contre le pouvoir donc je sais
effectivement que je suis publié partout
dans l'europe mais j'espère quand même
qu'ils auront à d'autres personnes
comment dire qui donc qui mérite plus
d'être surveillé que moi vous vous
trompez vous manie l'humour c'est la
chose la plus dangereuse pour un pouvoir
est incertaine nota c'est tout à fait
vrai c est simple parce que ces gens là
ne savent pas rire d'eux mêmes le cache
une cour ne s'est pas rire de lui-même
pas plus que poutine et je crois que
c'est très important
je crois que c'est très important de ne
pas cesser de faire des blagues sur ces
gens quand on commence de rire de ces
gens tu n'as plus peur d'eux et c'est
très important
de voir apparaître plein de même drôle
en biélorussie sur le cas chez le couple
un de ses tirs sur youtube
mais tout simplement
je ne peux pas me prendre au sérieux
quand on va me poser cette question je
ne peux pas me prendre au sérieux parce
que je ne veux pas ressembler à ces gens
là je ne veux pas penser que je suis
important parce que je ne veux pas
rentrer ressembler à ces gens qui
croient que eux ils sont toujours très
importants
revenons à votre
famille à vos amis vous avez des amis
ukrainiens vous avez des amis russes
vous avez une partie de votre famille
que je suis une partie de votre famille
qui est ukrainienne vous pouvez
expliquer à notre communauté et comment
ça se passe
est un super show c'est très compliqué
parce que je suis née à minsk qui était
une ville russophone qu'elle est
toujours une ville de reichshoffen
j'ai fait des études à l'école en
biélorusse mahler vient de russie et là
des racines russes mon père liens de le
cren il a des racines ukrainiennes et
russes je porte le nom de famille
craignent un jallet aussi se vend à kiev
qu'à moscou qu'à saint pétersbourg où
j'étais vous je travaillais et tous ces
croisements c'est comme les racines d'un
même arbre qui se croisent sous la terre
et qui sont tout à fait impossible de
rompre de séparer maintenant et donc
quand c'est quand quand ces événements
ont commencé j'ai aidé mes amis a
déménagé de kiev en leur chercher des
appartements à kiev à stockholm hier ici
à paris j'ai
j'ai parlé avec des amis de moscou qui
avait jadis travaillé sur la chaîne
d'offres qui avait parlé déjà donc qui
avait dit à quel point le régime de
poutine était affreux et à pois ça
allait
et tous mes collègues avec lesquels je
vais travailler maintenant les guerres
il est en cours de plus de 40 de 40
jours et on arrive toujours par
concevoir que cela s'est vraiment
produit il me semble tout le temps que
c'est un cauchemar que je vais réveiller
que je vais me réveiller et que tout
cela sera fini c'est quelque chose qu'on
ne se serait jamais imaginé moi je suis
un alarmiste voilà j'ai j'ai dit pendant
dix ans qu'il y aurait une grande de
guerre en europe mais j'avais je ne
pouvais jamais imaginé que c'est
l'ukraine que la russie allait attaquer
vous pensez qu'il est attaqué la
biélorussie qu'il allait prendre le
contrôle de la ville sous le signe
de conditions difficiles parce que quand
nous parlons a donc du fait que la
russie a pris le contrôle sur la
biélorussie on ne peut pas savoir quand
en quelle année cela s'est produit est
ce que ça vient de se produire ou est-ce
que ça s'est produit il ya cinq ans
formellement effectivement il ya des
drapeaux biélorusse que nous les
biélorusses ne considérons pas comme les
drapeaux de notre pays c'est un drapeau
soviétique que le cash and co avaient
choisi qui ne veut rien dire pour moi
pour moi le drapeau de mon pays c'est le
drapeau blanc rouge blanc et rouge avec
lesquels on sortait manifester et donc
le cash and co ne cesse aller voir
poutine et parler à poutine et on ne
sait pas à quel moment de sa vie il a
trahi la biélorussie on ne sait pas à
quel moment nous avons perdu notre
indépendance nous ne savons pas si on
est encore en dépendant au sommet celui
indépendant
on est ce qu'on va la perdre aujourd'hui
notre indépendance ou ou ensuite après
les événements d'avec le cren c'est
parce que nous n'avons pas de président
légitime à nous avons est une personne
qui a pris le pouvoir de force voilà
c'est imaginer que les terroristes qui
ont pris d'assaut le bataclan aurait
décidé de prendre aussi les elysées je
ne sais pas effectivement au siège de
votre président donc ici en ce moment là
au lieu de les abattre la police disait
ok on se tient les terroristes et la
remet donc à ses yeux le disais nous
aussi on soutient le terrorisme
j'imaginais la réaction des français et
un but réussi c'est ce qui s'est produit
c'est que le donc à une bande de
terroristes à plus le pouvoir et leur
retenue avec le soutien de la russie
vos amis votre famille mixez de
plusieurs nations comment ça se passe
leurs propres rapports entre eux est-ce
qu'il ya plus de clivage est ce que les
gens sont plus triste est ce que les
gens voient une solution se dessine est
devant eux où ils sont totalement
anéanti par ce qui se passe
vraiment très difficile
par exemple j'ai un catcheur télégramme
avec mes amis qu'on avait donc fait
pendant les manifestations pour pouvoir
se trouver si jamais quelqu'un est
arrêté ou amener dans un commissariat
est aujourd'hui de 7 personnes avec
lesquelles jal est manifestée à minsk à
dieu il ne reste qu'un seul à minsk six
personnes dont qui était le pays il y en
a un qui vit au portugal autre en
lituanie en troisième donc qu'il végète
en ukraine la quitter et c'est une
situation très difficile pour tout le
monde qu'on n'arrête pas de discuter par
exemple ma femme et le citoyenne russe
est pour elle c'est une catastrophe
parce que toute sa vie et s'était
prononcé et la dépouille battu contre
poutine et aujourd'hui elle est dans une
situation où elle est devenue donc à
partie du peuple agresseurs tandis que
elle elle avait toujours donc
été contre ce régime est depuis les 45
jours que la guerre continue elle pleure
parce qu'elle sent sa responsabilité
individuelle elle se dit que malgré tout
ce combat de toute sa vie et il n'a pas
fait ça elle n'a pas tout fait
correctement et c'est pour ça que donc
finalement cette guerre a commencé et
bien sûr pour les gens en ukraine qui se
sont retrouvés dans dans l'état d'une
catastrophe humanitaire
mais c'est difficile aussi pour les
citoyens russes qui ne n'aurais jamais
pensé qu'on puisse a démarré une telle
guerre en leur nom
les sanctions commencent est perçu par
la population normale des gens comme
vous et moi des gens comme les gens qui
sont avec nous en ce moment non dit le
pékin lambda avec respect d'ailleurs les
sanctions occidentales vers le peuple
russe vers le peuple biélorusse quelle
réaction ça produit chez eux il trouve
ça légitime
ils sont prêts à endurer y sont pas
prêts en dur et ils comprennent ils
comprennent pas
il ya deux mois c'est une question très
difficile parce que d'un côté j'ai
toujours appelé à introduire des
sanctions
mais il est important de comprendre que
nous sommes dans une situation
je l' ai déjà écrit quand nous observons
ce qui se passe en ukraine nous sommes
comme des personne qui regarde un match
de foot pré enregistré c'est déjà le
deuxième temps qui se déroulent et nous
on arrive seulement au début du premier
temps et ne réagissons aux événements du
premier temps tandis que c'est déjà la
deuxième mi-temps qui a commencé et des
événements sont tout autres et nous ne
réagisse sont toujours au premier
mettant les sanctions qui ont été
introduites aujourd'hui auraient dû être
introduites
en 2014 aussi dur est qu'elles sont
aujourd'hui et dans ce cas là on
n'aurait pas eu poutine et aujourd'hui
rien ne se serait produit mais
aujourd'hui à l'époque personne n'a
introduit de sanctions et aujourd'hui on
introduit des sanctions contre les gens
qui sont à l'étranger et qui dans leur
majorité
n'ont pas soutenu poutine ce qui est
important de comprendre c'est que les
sanctions elles ne frappent eux pas
aussi fort les gens qui sont allés à
l'intérieur du pays ils ne le feraient
peut pas aussi aussi gravement que les
gens qui sont à l'extérieur et qui sont
un général opposant à poutine il faut
dire que la moitié des citoyennes russe
n'a même pas de toilettes dans la maison
et pas dans la cour donc et il y a que
30 % de deux personnes qui ont le
passeport pour voyager et donc
70% n'ont jamais voyagé à l'étranger et
quand vous dites voilà on vous à fermer
les transports aériens vous pourriez
plus voyagé ces gens là ne réagissent
pas et donc les sanctions n'agissent pas
de la sorte enfin de la manière voulu
parce que donc en europe on se dit que
donc on va introduire les sanctions et
les gens vont finir par se révolter et
par descendre dans les rues mais nous
savons que les gens ont descendu sont
descendus en masse en 2012 quand donc
les gens étaient vraiment au maximum de
leurs de leur richesse de leur bien-être
et les gens qui sont pauvres en général
ne descendent pas dans la rue on voit
que donc l'instrument terre
est limité et peut-être effectivement
que si ces sanctions étaient introduites
contre la suisse ou un autre pays
européen
ce pays enfin le dirigeant de ce pays se
serait dit qu'il faut qu'il faudrait
changer quelque chose et donc bien sûr
que les sanctions il faut le continuer
il faut continuer à la pression sur la
russie mais il faut comprendre que ces
sanctions n'auront pas l'effet escompté
tous pour suivre les sanctions mais ne
rompt pas le résultat escompté
ce serait contre-productif la fin
oui nous ne savons pas comment ça finira
parce que nous ne savons pas comment la
société russe réagira à ce qui va se
passer ne ne savons même pas ce qui se
passera en russie d'ici un mois c'est
déjà un collapse
moi je comprends que mon livre mon
nouveau livre un réussi ne sera pas
publié de ce tout simplement parce qu'il
n'y a plus de papier sur lequel on
pourrait plus peu peur paraîtront en
livre donc c'est la question de la
réaction de la société ressources sur le
papier
même problème en france un
john isner je n'en sais rien ça fait
deux ans que je n'ai pas été en russie
parce que je risque d'être arrêtée là
bas
mais la question en fait c'est qu'il n'y
a pas de fin il n'y a pas de papiers et
le papier est devenu plus donc plus cher
que le rouble et aujourd'hui c'est le
papier enfin le plus cher sur la bourse
c'est le devis c'est la devise la plus
chère
tout est problématique a trouvé il n'y a
plus de donc de produits d'hygiène
il n'y a plus de produits d'alimentation
donc on interdit d'exporter la farine et
cetera et cetera nous ne savons pas
comment la société réagira
est ce que ça leur forcera à se dire que
poutine fait quelque chose de louche ou
est ce que c'est la propagande que leur
expliquera que c'est pas poutine qui
fait quelque chose de louche mais c'est
l'europe qui veulent le détruire et en
fait la majorité de gens qui est quoi la
propagande et crois que c'est l'europe
qui attaquent toujours la russie ce qui
veut donc détruire la grande de russie
que pauthe il n'a jamais fait une seule
erreur dans sa vie et donc aujourd'hui
ne pouvons pas savoir comment les
sanctions vont marcher on verra le
résultat peut-être dans un mois dans
quelques mois plus tard
comme on traduit en russe un jeu à somme
nulle
alors ce matin c'est comme ça c'est
littéralement comme ça que c'est très
bien et le mal heureusement je ne suis
pas un politicien ou enfin n'ont cessé
je suis très heureux à ne pas être
politicien j'ai toujours été observateur
j'étais quelqu'un qui essaie qui
essayait de fixer son temps qui essayait
de parler de ce qui se passait je
réussissais à prédire beaucoup de choses
et peut-être c'est justement cela qui
donc est un site qui vous incite à ces
questions parce qu'effectivement j'ai
dit des choses prophétique sur la russie
et la biélorussie
mais c'est très c'est très facile d'être
prophétique de prédire des choses en
russie en biélorussie il ya un écrivain
magnifique maxime aussi pauvre qui a dit
qu'en russie en dix ans touchant je mets
en 200 ans rien ne change c'est à dire
que tout simplement si tu décris ce qui
se passe ici et maintenant c'est
peut-être la même chose qui se passera
dans 10 ans et donc peut-être que dans
dix ans la russie aura toujours des
problèmes de papiers
maintenant que vous êtes heure d'europe
vous côté comment on fait pour vous
informer en europe vous utilisez vos
propres canaux et vous mixez avec les
les canaux occidentaux comment on fait
pour vos enfants et comment vous jugez
la propager la propagande la
contre-propagande occidentale
primitive et on voulait dire comment je
reçois des informations de la
biélorussie et de l'art est fier c'est
sa vie entre autres mais aussi la
fonction actuelle
plusieurs de mes amis restent toujours à
là bas nos francs je suis allé là bas ma
famille reste là bas
parlons par facebook que nous
communiquons par instagram
c'est par tous les médias possibles
on dit que c'est donc que ces réseaux
sociaux sont interdits en russie mais
tout le monde utilise le vpn donc on
peut on peut les appeler par zoom par
skype par télégramme ça marche toujours
dans ce sens il n'y a aucun problème
bien qu'en russie on dise tout de suite
oui ils vont fermer le youtube donc en
fait et aucun et aucun problème avec la
connexion avec
la réception des informations qui ne
cessent d'arriver de la base comment
vous maintenant d'europe vous percevez
la propagande et la contre propagande
occidentale
bien et que je ne perçois pas la
propagande parce que
je comprends depuis longtemps comment ça
marche je suis le dernier enfant
soviétique je suis allé à l'école en
1991 et je me souviens encore des
nouvelles soviétique de la propagande
soviétique
suite donc j'ai j'ai eu quand même une
période d'une vie assez libre donc je ne
les ai pas la pravda à l'époque tout
simplement parce que j'ai à l'époque je
ne les ai rien du tout mais je regardais
des actualités soviétique ensuite j'ai
regardé les actualités russe et j'ai
passé plusieurs années à travailler à
une chaîne indépendante et je voyais de
l'autre côté comment marche la
propagande jeu donc je comprends aussi
comment marche la censure je travaillais
dans un plateau télé très connue donc
sur la première chaîne qui s'appelait
projecteurs paris s'il tonne il y avait
quatre acteurs comiques qui donc lisez
un journal et qui faisait des blagues
dessus voilà ça donc ça paraissait le
soir est là donc c'est comme ça que j'ai
compris comment marcher la censure il
est important de comprendre que la
russie est un énorme pays et il y a
plusieurs fuseaux horaires donc le
programme tout d'abord donc sort à
vladivostok et puis très lentement donc
l'émission voyage à moscou et on
comprend que certains gags dans cette
émission qui est apparue donc tout
d'abord à vladivostok ne vont pas
jusqu'à moscou certaines blagues étaient
coupées à ekatérinbourg certaine hague
était coupée au niveau de kazan et là on
voyait de ses fins de nos propres yeux
comment marcher la censure et on voit
une blague tout à fait innocente sur
poutine sur un ministre ne finit pas son
voyage de vladivostok à moscou et dans
ce sens là je comprends très bien
comment fonctionne la propagande de la
censure l'autocensure et en ce qui
concerne la contre-propagande européenne
je crois que les 0
84 ans n'a d'abord technology mit vous
voulez dire de la propagande européenne
et qui travaille pour la russie non de
la propagande européenne à destination
des européens quand j'entendis
propagande on dit par exemple propagande
politique pour les tracts politiques que
là les politiciens nous envoie quand je
dis propagande ça veut dire comment les
médias
prépare les gens à la guerre comment on
explique la guerre rouge on
y annonce dans ses pas assez si j'ai
bien compris votre question je ne sais
pas si la propagande européenne prépare
les gens à la guerre
je comprends comment marcher la chaîne
russia today donc arty et nous voyons
maintenant les résultats dans cette
propagande et je crois qu'on les voit
même pas dans le sens que qu'elle aurait
préparé les gens ici à la guerre mais
nous voyons le résultat de des élections
en france du premier tour alors je ne
sais pas s'il existe un sondage mais je
crois qu'on pourrait facilement le faire
on pourrait demander donc s'intéresser à
la corrélation des spectateurs de rachat
today et de ceux qui ont donc ont voté
pour madame le pen et je crois que cette
corrélation entre à château-d'oex et
donc les votent pour marine le pen que
ce sera assez considérable peut-être que
je me trompe mais mais j'ai quand même
je doute parce que pendant plusieurs
années nous avons donc nous avons
insisté pour que à la chaîne russia
today ferme en europe et je voyais que
certains donc entre guillemets
intellectuels en europe
percevez la chaîne dans la chatte ed
comme un point de vue alternative soit
disant à la propagande américaine mais
il faut dire que dès dès le jour de la
création
donc il ne s'agissait pas du journalisme
il ne s'agissait pas de présenter un
autre point de vue c'était vraiment une
chaîne de propagande à la goebbels qui a
toujours travaillé pour la propagande et
pour servir au régime de poutine et ça
n'avait aucun autre objectif est donc
c'est très étrange de voir que les gens
ne le percevait pas qu'il prenait au
sérieux tout ce qui se disait dans cette
chaîne et donc si je comprends bien
aujourd'hui il ne marche pas en france
alors est ce qu'il y à une propagande
européenne donc
de l'autre côté je n'en sais rien parce
que je vis dans une petite maison en
suisse donc à la campagne et je suis
concentré sur les nouvelles qui viennent
du pays donc la vie européenne passant
un petit peu à côté vous parlez de herti
comme vecteur de propagande les suisses
le gouvernement suisse ont décidé de pas
interdire rt parce qu'ils disent que
interdire ce n'est pas la meilleure
façon de combattre la propagande qu'est
ce que vous en pensez vous qu'ils
connaissent et la suisse il ya peu de
sous
est-ce que vous m'entendez
là c'est bon ok on reprend j'étais en
train de vous dire vous connaissez bien
la suisse vous parliez de rti le
gouvernement suisse a décidé de ne pas
interdire arte parce que c'était à leurs
yeux pas la meilleure façon de combattre
la propagande d'interdire
à quoi paniquer qu'elle allait donc
qu'elle a les moyens qu'ils proposent
pour le coin pour la combattre est-ce
qu'ils ont est ce que le gouvernement
suisse a une méthode alternative pour
comprendre pour combattre la propagande
à qu'est ce qu'ils proposent
c'est une question assez ouverte pour
moi parce que si vous proposez de ne pas
fermer à château des vous devez lui
opposer quelque chose on comprend qu'un
réussi aujourd'hui quand on se pose la
question comment la russie donc a pu
aller jusqu'au pont où elle se trouve
aujourd'hui un réussi avec le public
russe avec les citoyens russes ce
n'était pas une seule chaîne à
château-d'oex pas deux mais une dizaine
de plus la censure plus le censure qui
vit dans les gens depuis les
les temps de l'union soviétique
et donc quand vous dites ok on laisse se
lâcher dans la château-d'oex parce que
on veut soi disant la liberté de presse
et la liberté d'expression
il me semble qu'il est très important de
ne pas confondre la liberté de la presse
la liberté d'expression et la liberté de
manipulation et ça c'est une question
morale et éthique est ce qu'on admet la
liberté de manipulation tout en sachant
comment cette chaîne fonctionne tout en
sachant pourquoi cette chaîne fonctionne
je ne peux pas répondre pour le
gouvernement suisse je ne connais pas
leur région pour laisser donc émettre la
chaîne russia today peut-être ils sont
aujourd'hui la société suisse où la
culture suisse peuvent opposer quelque
chose à la propagande mais j'ai peur que
c'est un jeu très dangereux dans lequel
ils ne peuvent pas estimé tous les
risques ils sous-estiment peut être donc
le bon fonctionnement de la propagande
russe et à quel point ces faits avec du
talent mondialement parlant il ya une
dans les pays occidentaux par dont il ya
une défiance du public envers sa presse
locale et nationale
comment vous journalistes humoristes
écrivains
et musiciens
vous
percevez cette défiance est pourquoi
je j'ai grandi dans un pays où
malheureusement on faisait trop
confiance à la télé après quoi j'ai
travaillé dans un pays où
malheureusement on faisait beaucoup trop
confiance à la télévision de l'état donc
c'est un problème anvers je crois que
je vais le faire j'ai dit ah
oui mais je crois que quand une quand tu
ne fais pas confiance quand tu doutes
quand tu mets donc tout en question
c'est très bien c'est très utile c'est
très sain de douter quand cette
ressource donc marche c'est à dire tu
peux obtenir une forme d information
d'une source puis aller le vérifier à
une autre source puis demander à une
troisième source et on essaie de
d'assembler un vitrail à partir des
fragments malheureusement les gens ont
réussi en lui la russie n'ont pas cette
expérience de pensée critique je ne peux
pas parler pour tous je ne peux pas à
généraliser mais malheureusement les
chiffres que montrer les résultats des
élections pendant des années et le point
donc ce
ou la russie se retrouvent aujourd'hui
nous montre que malheureusement les gens
se sont retrouvés dans une situation où
ils croient très facilement ce qu'on
leur raconte ils ne sont pas prêtes à
douter et c'est en fait ça me met très
mal à l'aise de douter de quelque chose
d'un côté c'est bien d'écouter de la
vérité mais c'est bien des c'est bien
d'entendre aussi se dire comment la vie
est faite et c'est très important de
comprendre comment marche la proportion
de russes le sens de l'à propos de la
propagande de russes et de ne pas donner
qu'un seul point de vue que vous devez
croire le sens de la propagande russe
c'est vous donner beaucoup plus beaucoup
de variantes de vérité en même temps de
façon que vous ne savez plus sur
quelques marchés et après avoir donné
c'était donc c'est énorme cette
multitude d'options et elle vous donne
une version finale à laquelle c'est
facile de croire et donc au début les
gens en russie ils se sont auto début
déboussolés par cette multitude de
vérité et finalement ils saisissent avec
plaisir donc la vérité donné par la
propagande officielle parce que c'est
une sorte de bouée de sauvetage dans le
monde d'information je crois que c'est
important de comprendre que la
propagande de russes est fait de façon
beaucoup plus compliqué qu'on ne le
croit et donc je suis très content si
vous dites qu ici en france les gens
sont quand même enclin à se doute pas à
douter tout mettre en question je crois
que c'est une c'est une très bonne
qualité la seule chose c'est qu'il faut
pas vraiment exagéré
et aller chercher trop loin parfois il
faut juste comprendre ce qui se passe et
mettre un point pour comprendre que
poutine ou le cash est conscient des
dictateurs on n'a pas besoin d'accumuler
beaucoup d'informations
comment ça se passe en termes de prison
de torture d'intimidation est ce qu'il
ya de la subtilité ou celle méthodes
soviétiques encore là là les allumettes
sous les eaux il vous prendre par les
pieds il vous tabasse par les matons
comment ça se passe c'est les flics qui
vous tabasse ils vous mettent des
matraques dans les fesses comment ça se
passe
3 la chaîne rojas il se passe des choses
tout à fait à trop ce qu'on n'arriverait
pas à s'imaginer en 2002 par exemple à
présent
ces choses sont donc nombreuses
aujourd'hui quand les biélorusses
ddd 102 pour protester contre la guerre
en ukraine ne savons que toute l'europe
a été donc enchantés par la belarusse il
ya deux ans tout le monde exprime s à
solidarité tout le monde disait on se
tient bien le russe bélarusse est alors
aujourd'hui donc sur le fond de
l'ukraine
sera vite oubliée la russie est donc
on croit que la biélorussie et complice
d'agresseurs us et tandis qu'il y à
400000 donc qui sont partis il ya des
gens qui sont obturées et pendant donc
les protestations anti guerre des
milliers de personnes ont été arrêtées
torturées et matraqué et aujourd'hui en
2022 ont fait les gens montrer d'en
décider ils mettent du gaz lacrymogène
pour les torturer coach non non il ya
donc ces tortures sont multiples mais
c'est très souvent il s'agit aussi de la
torture émotionnel par exemple un
journaliste est bien le russe connu à il
a passé un mois dans
dans la cellule pour les condamnés à
mort donc quelqu'un qui ne faisait qu
écrire il se retrouvait tout d'un coup
donc rester dans les cellules pour un
condamné à mort et j'ai décrit les
tortures donc que subissent les femmes
dans les prisons biélorusse par exemple
ce sont des conditions atroces par
exemple dans la bio le russe dans la
prison biélorusse vous pouvez avoir du
beurre seulement si vous êtes donc
positif au sida et sinon bah non vous
n'aurez pas de beurre
si donc c'est la question de ce qu'on
entend par la torture par exemple quand
vous êtes dans la cellule personne
n'étant la lumière vous restez dans une
cellule où il ya de la lumière 24 heures
sur 24
parfois on voulait se sortir donc à
l'extérieur pour une heure voilà mais
des fois il vous laisse pas sortir aux
par exemple le marina kolesnikova donc
une opposante
on ne lui permet pas la correspondance
c'est à dire on ne les transmet pas des
lettres et notre sport on ne transmet
pas les lettres qui elle écrit
aujourd'hui donc dans la russie où il ya
à peu près 40 millions de personnes il
ya 500 prisonniers politiques donc en
biélorussie où il ya neuf millions de
personnes il ya plus de milliers de
prisonniers politiques et tout le monde
est torturé différemment il
et donc quand vous me parlez de la
torture il faut comprendre qu'ils n'ont
pas donc un kit de 10 torture c'est
toute une encyclopédie c'est c'est une
multitude de torture qui sont impliqués
tous les jours et des gens différemment
les gens différents par exemple quand
après la manifestation vous arrivez dans
une cellule pour 4 ou ailier à 30 40
personnes j'ai intégré une femme
donc qui se trouvait dans une cellule
pour femmes est donc en fait si jamais
il y en a une qui qui se lèvent les
autres doivent rester assise parce que
sinon elle aura même pas le temps la
place pour sortir aux toilettes donc les
gens dorment
dans les cellules de façon haute et ris
parce qu'ils ne rentrent pas tout
simplement elles savent pas s'allonger
et iliad et donc les gens
les gens dorment à tour de rôle eliane
acquiert il y en a qui s'allongent et un
autre qui attend je crois que on peut
donc on peut faire toutes les missions
pour parler des tortures à dans les
prisons biélorusse ça me rappelle les
centres de rétention administratif à
bayonne le fait de dormir en tetris vous
parliez d'un écrivain dans une toute
petite cellule dans le couloir de la
mort
votre position votre perception de ce
qui se passe avec julian assange
il ya deux mois je
je connais très mal avec toutes les
péripéties de julian assange je vais
vous écrire que je m'imagine oui
j'imagine ce qui est ce qui se passe
je comprends que souvent nous imaginons
que certains pays donc sont autorisés à
faire quelque chose et d'autres pays ne
sont pas autorisées et que certains pays
se permettent donc
soit disant pour la lutte de la vérité
de faire plus de choses que les autres
je crois que c'est inconcevable ce qui
se passe avec un sens je crois que un
journaliste doit doit rester en liberté
et parler de ce qu'il veut parler je
crois que donc s'il ya des choses
donc qu'ils disent la vérité sur notre
société on ne devrait ne devrait pas les
cacher on devrait donc
tout mettre donc
auto mettre au clair et
donc à son jeu normalement il ne devrait
pas faire donc autant d'années
on l'épreuve est moi je comprends que
j'ai été censuré en russie et je
comprends que quand je fais un interview
par exemple je faisais une interview en
pologne pour un grande part dans un
grand journal est temps que je
critiquais la russie il avait le russe
il les journalistes étaient très
contents mais dès que j'ai commencé à
critiquer la polonia et dire que donc il
ya des choses impossibles qui se passe
avec les avortements la liste noire à la
télé avec ce qui se passe donc avec les
droits de femmes ils ont tous coupés de
mon interview rien de ça ne subsiste à
la télévision polonaise et quand j'ai
fait mon donc quand j'ai été interviewé
en hongrie où mon livre venait de
paraître j'ai été bien accueilli mais
dès que j'ai commencé à poser des
questions sur urban ça a été coupée au
si et quand j'ai demandé où tout cela
était parti le monde y va tout
simplement cessé pas rentrer dans les
limites d'interview je crois qu'on est
confronté à cela partout
mais on ne peut pas quand même enfin
comparer
les abîmes dans le précipice dans lequel
la russie tomber dans lequel tombe
peut-être la pologne mais il faut dire
que ces dictatures se transmettent comme
des virus et si jamais donc si jamais en
rade le moment où ça devient une
dictature on ne pourra jamais rattraper
cela parce que ces gens là et ils
n'aiment pas se retourner
un arrière je ne voudrais pas être
alarmiste mais je crois que si la
société accepte quelque chose elle
rendra acceptable autre chose encore et
autre chose et vous vous allez glisser
vers la dictature sans même le savoir en
2004 j'ai déménagé en russie au moment
où loukachenko à fermer l'université je
faisais mes études et en 2004 la russie
était plus libéral que la biélorussie et
l'accueillez les étudiant exilé de la
biélorussie à l'époque l'éducation
l'éducation libéral était important
importante pour ce pays moi j'étais dans
une école je pouvais choisir mes
matières et donc il s'agit d'une dizaine
d'années enfin que la réussi à passer du
dégel de medvedev et jusqu'au point de
démarrer la guerre
donc à mon avis on doit donc on doit
traiter avec beaucoup d'attention c'est
signal d'alarmé d'où qu'ils viennent de
la pologne des usa ou de les enlever
on signale palerme est ce que vous vous
rappelez des prisons et vols secrets de
la cia en europe où il torturait des
gens sur le territoire européen parce
que c'était quand même interdit chez eux
ça vous a pas rappelé quelque chose qui
ressemblait ce qui se passe chez vous
il ya la 4g pour encore eiffage connaît
malins les tortures enfin pas parce que
je ne
je ne vois pas ce qui se passe avec les
services secrets je comprends très bien
leurs méthodes tout simplement
je ne peux pas donc je ne peux pas
travailler avec toutes les tous les
horreurs du monde à genève il ya un
endroit magnifique ou sur la même classe
il y a plus de donc 60 tante qui vous
font qui attire votre attention avec
donc les atrocités qui se passe
aujourd'hui dans le monde toutes les
autres sociétés en ligne à un moment il
semble que les choses les plus horribles
se passe en biélorussie et ensuite on
regarde aussi dit que non la chose la
plus à trop se passe en ukraine et à
genève sur cette place tu comprends que
le monde il va mal parce que dans 60
dans 60 endroits du monde est un enfer
qui est en cours un enfer on devrait
corriger tout de suite la chine le tibet
etc mais comme tu n'es qu'une petite
personne ne tu ne peux pas tout faire
je ne peux pas combattre toutes les
horreurs pour moi elle est impossible de
faire que l'inacceptable restait
inacceptable dans mon pays et donc c'est
sur cela que je suis con se concentrait
je suis concentré sur les tortures qui
se passe dans mon pays dans les bus de
russie dans les rues si je voudrais que
ça ne se passe pas dans mon pays je suis
à l'intérieur de ce petit jeu comme je
comprends comment ça se passe je peux
parler de ces mécanismes je travaille
avec les archives je travaille avec le
mémorial qui a été interdite est
dispersé je travaille avec le musée de
gouda de moscou qui va être je crois
fermée et interdite si peu de temps et
c'est pour ça que je crois qu'il y à des
journalistes en europe et en amérique
qui est ce que prend de ces questions
ici et moi je vais m'occuper des
questions de mon pays tout simplement
parce que ne peux pas m'occuper de tout
en même temps je n'aurais pas assez de
force et je deviendrais fou mais je
crois que je deviens déjà fou alors
pourquoi vous pensez que vous devenez
vous devez des choux
comment ça se manifeste vous dormez pas
vous avez vous fait des dermatites vous
êtes obligé de prendre des pilules
vous fait des cauchemars vous avez des
pensées morbides
pas ce jeu suit les traces de mon père
je bois beaucoup
pour l'instant c'est que du vin mais
peut-être celle de viendrait plus grave
est sérieusement parlant c'est une
question difficile
je ne suis pas tellement plongé dans le
journalisme
donc pour attaquer des thèmes des termes
durs mais j'écris en tant que littéraire
donc sur les thèmes assez durs dans la
croix rouge j'ai écrit sur le destin de
la femme qui est passé par le goulag et
dans mon nouveau roman j'ai écrit sur le
premier directeur du crématorium de
moscou qui vivait donc une double vie
dans la journée ils faisaient des
funérailles de gorki de et de maïakovski
et la nuit et le brûler les ports amener
de la ligue en cas pour cacher les
crimes de du pouvoir soviétique
et donc quand on écrit pendant trois ans
en livres sur une personne qui travaille
dans un crématorium
donc équipe qui raconte comment on brûle
les corps comment il faut bien mettre
les corps pour que ça rentre mieux dans
le four quand tu travailles tous les
jours sur un livre qui te dit que en
vérité les gens qui construisait
les fours d'auschwitz donc la société
allemande qui les construisent avait
d'abord construire des fours à moscou ça
laisse une empreinte donc tu es là à
lire constamment les documents d
archives et quand tu comprends toutes
ces horreurs qui se passait dans l'union
soviétique et tulle et donc tu le
laisses très la traversée ton corps est
ensuite il est un fils de 10 ans qui
vient de te voir qu'il n'est pas content
qui est triste à cause d'une petite
chose on commença donc
on commence à le gronder à lui dire mais
pourquoi tu me plains de ces choses là
quand il a eu des gens qui ont vécu des
choses beaucoup plus difficiles et un
moment tu te dis mais merde mais qu'est
ce que tu dis qu'est ce que tu dis un
gars de neuf ans donc qui n'a jamais
connu de tout ça et pour lequel
la grande de tragédies du moment c'est
l'impossibilité de jouer à minecraft
bien sûr que ça laisse l'empreinte sur
toute ta vie au moment où j'écrivais la
croix rouge je n'aurais je n'arrivais
pas à percevoir la réalité parce que
dans ma tête j'étais tout le temps dans
l'année 1937 donc tu vis dans l'horreur
de ce qui se passait mais le russie est
en fait tu donc que tu veux traces des
parallèles entre ce qui se passe en
biélorussie maintenant en ligne est ce
qui s'est passé en 1937 et il faut quand
même sortir de toutes ces horreurs et il
faut devenir un bon mari pour ma femme
en bon père pour un mon fils un ami
marrant pour ses amis et tu comprends
que tu ne peut pas moralement tu ne peux
pas le faire après avoir fini un roman
tu ne fais rien je me suis senti un
marathonien qui a fait un marathon et
quelques qui ne plus qu'il ne peut plus
bouger je croyais que je n'allais rien
écrire pendant six mois après la croix
rouge est là quand j'ai fini ce roman
sur le crématorium et on me demande
qu'est ce que vous écrivez
maintenant je ne comprends pas comment
les gens font pour me poser cette
question parce que pour moi il est
évident que je ne peux rien écrire
j'essaie de respirer tout simplement de
recommencer un marché de recommencer à
respirer
parce que ce sont des sujets
qui donc qui te mange à la petite
cuillère à l'intérieur et finalement tu
te sens complètement vide et tu sens que
tu n'as
que tu n'as plus aucune force et donc ça
je ne voudrais pas que
que ça a l'air d'une coquetterie je ne
voudrais pas plaindre contre me plaindre
contre mon propre travail mais quand
même quand même ça te déployer un petit
peu
c'est un travail toxiques c'est un
travail qui vous mange de l'intérieur
pourquoi vous faites c'est pour votre
fils c'est pour votre peuple
c'est pour l'humanité quand vous voyez
ces zombies dans la rue qui ne
connaissent pas leur propre histoire les
atrocités que l'histoire nous donner à
vivre on va être condamné à les revivre
on les revit
pourquoi pourquoi vous faites ça et
comment vous percevez les zombies autour
de nous
notamment jeté achats que je crois que
je dois le faire c'est ta vocation
je crois que c'est peut-être donc le
travail de sisyphe mais tu dois le faire
je crois que les gens de leur propre
volonté n'iront pas dans les archives
donc tu dois leur parler de ces
documents tu dois leur parler du fait
que les armées rue les pour ce russe en
entrant dans le camp de concentration de
buchenwald
ils ont démonté les baraques ils ont
pris les planches ils les ont donc
emporté
dans l'union soviétique et façon et qui
a ils ont remonté de même planche les
baraques au goulag et c'est là qu'on se
demande si c'était bien le bien qui a
vaincu le mal pendant la deuxième guerre
mondiale ou c'est juste un mal qui avant
qu'un autre et tu dois en parler et
alors aujourd'hui on demande le tribunal
d'une rambert après les événements en
ukraine est pour moi la grande de
question c'est qui veut le faire comment
on va le faire au tribunal de nuremberg
l'union soviétique était représenté par
le procureur rudenko qui lui était
personnellement responsable des
exécutions au tribunal pendant les
années 30 donc c'était lui qui signer
les procès verbal des comités de 3
c'est lui qui fusille et les gens et
c'est pas parce qu'il représentait le
bien qu'il a été envoyé à nuremberg mais
parce qu'il savait très bien comment
fonctionnait le mal et c'est très
important d'en parler mon dernier roman
commence par le fait que dans l'union
soviétique
entre en 1937 il ait eu 111 milles
personnes qui ont été fusillés pour
avoir soi disant travailler pour les
services de renseignement russes
polonais pardon donc ils étaient
considérés comme des espions polonais
tandis que tous les résidents sans doute
toutes les résidences des espions
polonais ne contenait que deux cents
personnes donc quelqu'un travailler à
temps plein quelqu'un travailler juste
un étang mais de toute façon tous les
effectifs de l'espionnage polonais ne
contenait que deux cents personnes
tandis que dans l'union soviétique on a
fusillé
111000 soi-disant espions polonais nous
devons en parler nous devons le dire aux
gens qui se promènent à moscou avec les
drapeaux rouges et doivent comprendre ce
que c'est que ce drapeau il ya eu des
gens qui émettait leurs autocollants à
moscou deux sur leur voiture
1941 1945 on peut leur faire c'est à
dire qu'on pouvait refaire la guerre
contre l'allemagne et quand j'écris que
l'union soviétique se fichait de ces
prisonniers donc que ses prisonniers
n'étaient pas donc on ne peut pas qu'ils
étaient tout simplement abandonné et je
voudrais savoir qu'est ce qu'elle
voudrait refaire qu'est-ce qu'elle
pourrait refaire en réalité je ne sais
pas si je peux vraiment ouvrir les yeux
à ces gens mais je doit au moins essayer
de le faire mon objectif c'est de leur
donner ce livre mon objectif c'est de
faire que le livre soit lui quelle sera
la conclusion qu'ils tireront de ce
livre je n'en sais rien mais je dois au
moins faire tout mon possible pour qu'il
reçoive ces informations comment vous
expliquez cette nostalgie chez certains
russes une grande partie des russes j'ai
l'impression de l'ex union soviétique
quand ils nous disent
on avait la scolarité gratuite
pratiquement toutes été pris en charge
on n'avait pas beaucoup mais il est à
s'occuper de nous maintenant c'est
compliqué et l'inflation
comment vous expliquez cette nostalgie
3 c'est bien de l'expliquer pas par la
nostalgie mais par la totale j c'est une
totale j de l'union soviétique
c'est à dire totalitarisme plus
nostalgie ça vous fait un mot-valise
donc totale
j7 total guy de l'union soviétique
il est important de comprendre
qu'aujourd'hui ces gens là n'ont plus de
quoi être fier sa part d'avoir jadis
donc fait le vol l'espace le premier vol
de l'espace et d'avoir jadis
vaincu dans la deuxième guerre mondiale
depuis il n'y a pas eu de grandes
victoires il faut comprendre que ça
reste tellement dans les mentalités
aujourd'hui le 9 mai le jour de victoire
sur les chaînes
sur les chaînes russes de sport il
montre l'équipe de hockey russe
remporté une victoire contre l'équipe de
l'allemagne de hockey et je me rappelle
que
donc il y avait un jour où allah
l'équipe donc
l'équipe de russie a perdu contre
l'équipe du canada ils n'ont pas voulu
montrer cette défaite ils ont re montré
la victoire donc de la russie contre
l'allemagne et les gens n'ont rien
compris ils croyaient qu'elle regardait
ça en direct et que c'était toujours les
réussi qui remportait une victoire sur
l'allemagne et donc c'est une
catastrophe parce qu'on est face aux
gens qui n'ont pas eu d'autres victoires
et c'est une victoire donc qui rend
possible la guerre à l'ukraine
aujourd'hui parce que la propagande dit
que c'est la guerre contre denain 6-2
contre le nazisme qui continue et les
gens aujourd'hui ils sentent qu'ils donc
qu'ils sont des héritiers donc des
vainqueurs de la deuxième guerre
mondiale et qu'il continue à combattre
le nazisme qui a fleuri à nu cren les
gens donc on sait total j pour alors
passé est très important moi je suis
absolument convaincu peut-être que je
n'ai pas raison mais moi je suis
absolument convaincu que poutine aussi
que le cushion co ne combattent pas le
cren ne combattent pas l'europe ne
combattent pas les états unis poutine le
cachet au combat tout le temps ils
combattent le futur petit ne le cachons
qu on vraiment peur le futur ils veulent
retourner en arrière
veut retourner dans le passé en tout les
européens pensent donc
comment comment faire un internet plus
rapide il passe du 4g aux 5 g poutine
est le cas chez nous et je sais de leurs
lentilles re de le fermer de fer que
l'internet n'existent plus parce qu'ils
comprennent et règles de la vie dans le
passé ils ne comprennent ils ne
comprennent pas quelles règles de la vie
seront dans le futur ils comprennent
comment remporter les élections au passé
mais pas dans le futur
poutine n'a jamais participé aux débats
et il rêve de se retrouver au passé on
n'a pas besoin de débat
et on voit ce rideau de fer tombé de
vitesse et des deux côtés d'ailleurs
parce que poutine rêve de retourner au
passé parce qu'elle veut aller dans le
passé son idée fixe est dit que la
catastrophe géopolitique prince
principal du vent du xxème siècle c'est
l'effondrement de l'urss et donc il
faudrait bien rebâtir celui ray cette
richesse
dans les dîners ions d'ukraine il ya des
nazis en ukraine oui ou non et si oui
combien de % aux dernières élections
il ya deux mois j'étais un artiste et je
crois que les nazis il y en a dans tous
les pays du monde y compris en ukraine
et ensuite c'est la question de la
question donc à quel point votre
propagande de peu
donc exagéré le fait d'avoir les nazis
je ne sais pas il ya peut-être pas un
seul nazie en france mais je crois que
quelque chose me suggère qu'on va en
trouver quand même quelques-uns et dans
ce sens là elle y à des nazis en
biélorussie
la biélorussie qui a vraiment souffert
maximum des nazis il y en a un en
ukraine et sans doute donc ce n'est pas
une invention et ils sont là bas
physiquement mais ce que nous devons
comprendre ce que le président actuel de
l'ukraine saint juif russophone qui même
dans donc pendant pendant la guerre il
voudrait il s'inquiète pour que donc la
population russophone n'est pas de
problème après toutes ces horreurs qui
qui se passe donc dire que le tour se
diriger par les nazis qu'ils auront
ce que je voulais dire c'est que malgré
les horreurs donc de la guerre voilà
malgré tout ces horreurs
que le cren éprouve aujourd'hui donc à
part les actions soviétique par
l'agression russe pardon
il y à une ville totalement russophone
donc détruire les villes de mario paul
mes amis ukrainiens
il supprime les lettres les lettres
cyrillique de leur téléphone et commence
à écrire seulement un ukrainien les gens
qui donc a qui ont toujours parlé
russe il commença par les ukrainiens
personne n'a jamais fait pour l'unité du
peuple ukrainien autant que poutine il
n'y a eu jamais une seule personne qui
aurait
tant fait pour cette unité nationale que
poutine je crois que peut-être faire
plusieurs années il faudrait à mettre un
monument ou de poutine c'est parce que
c'est lui qui a tout fait pour que je
craigne 1 commence à se percevoir comme
un peuple ukrainien
et donc mais malgré cela et malgré le
fait que la russie s'occupe de génocide
en ukraine poutine détruit en ligne tout
le pays et laissé de le raser de la
terre zelensky continue à penser à
s'inquiéter pour la population
russophone et ses ministres continuent à
parler russe donc c'est ridicule de dire
que le cren pour être un état nazi
tandis que les groupes nés en asie vous
pouvez les trouver dans n'importe quel
pays je vais me faire l'avocat du diable
je vais lire un commentaire qu'on a sur
notre forum
en ukraine est ce qu'il ya des rues ou
noms d'anciens nazis
yanis dans mon à vérifier tous les
tournois je crois qu'il ya des rues sans
doute qui est donc qui porte le nom de
stéphane bendera je crois que la rue
stepan bandera existe en russie sans
aucun doute ensuite je ne pouvais ni
bien sûr
ensuite nous pouvons pas nous poser la
question est ce que c'est la question de
la russie où est ce que c'est la
question de le pen si tu veux pas de
mode dolce la victorieuse 7 ans ben deja
c était une personne qui combattaient
pour l'indépendance de l'ukraine
ce qui était lié avec l'allemagne donc
nazis pendant l'occupation
c'était une personne et qui a été
enterré à munich qui a fait de la prison
mais qui au contraire du général vlasov
qui avait servi dans l'armée rouge et
qui passait du côté de hitler
il faut dire que ben deja à un moment a
refusé de collaborer avec les nazis donc
il y a eu des bataillons d'un des rares
qui continuer la résistance dans les
forêts mais c'est je crois
qu'aujourd'hui c'est la question de le
cren de l'état qui décide par lui-même
comment il doit appeler ses rues je
crois que donc cette question sous
entend alors de dire regardez il ya des
rues dans l'ukraine qui sont nommés en
l'honneur des nazis et cela justifie
l'intervention de la russie rien ne
justifie
il a réussi utilise beaucoup d'arguments
bizarre
la russie utilise beaucoup d'arguments
bizarre mais vous n'avez aucun droit
de venir avec des armes dans un autre
pays quels que soient les noms des rues
la question du nom des rues doit être
décidé par les citoyens ukrainiens entre
eux vous pouvez appeler à la discussion
vous pouvez dire que c'est inacceptable
vous pouvez dire que vous êtes concernés
vous pouvez parler autant que vous
voulez mais vous n'avez pas le droit de
bombarder les villes d'un autre pays
parce que vous n'avez pas vous n'aimez
pas ce choix vous n'aimez pas l'histoire
de ces gens vous n'aimez pas le fait
qu'après la famine de l'ukraine bendera
s'est mise à faire la guerre contre la
contre l'union soviétique ont peut-être
ils peuvent avoir un million de rue qui
sont nommés de façon qu'on n'aime pas
que les russes n'aiment pas mais mais en
cette année on pourrait on pourrait le
dise qu on pourrait en discuter mais ce
n'est pas le prétexte pour intervenir
dans un autre pays
je crois que ce sont des choses tout à
fait élémentaire et même mon fils qu'il
ya dix ans il le comprend très bien
question internet
comment perçoit-il les événements de
maidan en 2014
mais selon jana difficile aujourd'hui
parce que tout d'un coup je devais un
expert de le cren attendu ce que j'ai
jamais été un expert de ce qui se passe
en ukraine j'ai toujours vécu en
biélorussie et en russie
je peux parler de mon propre sentiment
de maidan 2014 à de tous les matins
nous regardions tous les mailles dalle à
envier le réussi avec beaucoup de
fascination nous soutenions tout cela et
nous donc nous nous émettions beaucoup
d'espoir parce que nous croyons que si
le cren arrivé à s'arracher donc de
cette étreinte du grand frère russe
alors nous un jour on pourrait aussi le
faire je crois que la raison de ce qui
s'est passé en biélorussie en 2020
tout cela c'est devenu possible parce
que nous avons vu l'exemple de nos amis
ukrainiens nous avons vu que si les
millions des gens descendaient dans les
rues ça pouvait avoir un résultat ça se
pouvait amener à quelque chose et donc
mon attitude envers ce qui s'est passé
c'est très simple moi j'admire est
toujours les gens qui descendent et dans
les rues je sais que sur youtube il ya
beaucoup d' experts en géopolitique qui
comprennent pourquoi donc le maiden est
arrivé quelles étaient ses raisons
comment les états unis les oligarques
que l'union européen a participé au
maidan et donc être ensemble sur youtube
ça me donne à croire que tout le monde
doit participer sauf les gens sentent
sauf les jours sauf les gens du peuple
moi je suis une personne qui
quand il ya eu des protestations en
biélorussie en 2010 ou plus tard en 2020
j'étais à moscou à saint pétersbourg je
me mettais dans ma voiture je parcourais
780 kilomètres en voiture pour
participer aux protestations parce que
je croyais qu à part donc écrire et
faire du journalisme c'était important
pour moi en tant que citoyen d'aller
manifester de retrouver avec mes amis
sur une place donc sur la place
principale de l'est
donc est de protester
et quand on me dit que ce que donc que
mon départ donc à mon petit café à une
station d'essence dans la nuit que tout
cela était payée ou a été initiée par
les états unis pour moi c'est très drôle
parce que je savais que je le faisais
tout simplement parce que je ne pouvais
pas rester à la maison sans rien faire
et donc pour répondre cours à votre
donner une réponse courte à votre
question madame a également inspiré
est-ce que vous avez suivi le gilet
jaune
yabo j'ai été un jour témoin d'une
manifestation parce que je me trouvais
ce jour ce jour là à paris au moment où
d'une manifestation du gilet jaune
je me suis retrouvé au centre de la
manifestation par hasard je rêverais de
pouvoir avoir ces bus et ses
manifestations chez nous la répression
des zizou vous a fait penser à la russie
menace est difficile de comparer parce
que je ne sais pas si vous me racontez
les répressions qui se faisait contre
les jets les jaunes jeu je voyais qu'on
connaissait de les disperser si vous en
dit plus je pourrais en parler
c'est très difficile de comparer parce
que je je je ne connais pas sa
répression
procédures judiciaires expéditive
technique contre-insurrectionnelle digne
d'un pays du tiers monde tire dans la
tête pour faire des mutilés bien visible
est ce que c'est un petit parfum de
russie
aux principaux cas réussi pour l'instant
on n'a pas encore tiré lors des
manifestations ils ont matraqué les
manifestants peut-être qu'il y ait
qu'ils ont donc appliqué des balles de
caoutchouc je n'en sais rien en
biélorussie on a tiré sur la foule avec
des armes à feu on tuer les gens ils
tiraient sur les gens qui s'enfuyaient
et tirer dans le dos et donc on peut en
parler sur l'exemple de biélorussie ça
c'est tout à fait inacceptable dans
n'importe quel pays je ne comprends pas
pourquoi il faut tirer sur les gens qui
vont manifester
je peux dire que la manifestation dans
laquelle je me suis retrouvé c'était à
côté du panthéon
ça bougeait je n'ai trouvé aucune
crainte donc en me trouvant dans une
manifestation à paris et quand on se
trouve dans une manifestation habile
russie on comprend que donc
tu vois des policiers en uniforme mais
il ya aussi énormément de policiers
qu'on appelle l'été car c'est à dire les
silencieux qui sont habillés un
manifestant est donc parmi les gens qui
sont à côté de toi lors de la
manifestation qui ne comprend pas le
quai donc est un partisan comme toi et
lequel va finir par te feras tu es et tu
te traîner vers donc le panier à salade
je crois que pour l'instant la police
française n'utilise pas ce genre de
tactique et les gens peuvent distinguer
ses camarades et ses adversaires il voit
quand même où se trouve la police et où
il n'y a pas de police je crois qu'on
est quand même un petit peu encore un
contrôle de situation c'est pas le cas
en france y ait des flics qui se
déguisent
mais bon
mais aussi on a du panier à salade
revenons à la biélorussie ça tape
toujours bien dans la caisse dans la lah
vote votre peur classe dictatorial le
père la fille tous les copains ou une
bonne petite fortune personnelle des
chasses gardées en termes de contrats de
la corruption va bat son plein est ce
qu'il ya des juges encore opérationnels
des juges spécialisés dans les questions
financières qui peuvent travailler à ce
que la justice et le colis du pouvoir ce
temps très rapidement sur la justice
comment ça se passe
qui a demandé que le tribunal est
indépendant on n'existe plus en
biélorussie depuis une vingtaine
d'années
je ne peux même pas m'imaginer
que qu'il y ait une personne au tribunal
qu'ils puissent se prendre telle ou
telle décision sans avoir demandé
conseil à quelqu'un si ce n'est pas une
petite décision genre est ce qu'on lui
donne donc quinze 15 jours dans en tôle
ou une amende mêmes donc même tout cela
est donc la tôle les amendes pour les
manifestants tout cela est donc se fait
en accord avec les supérieurs donc elle
est jugée en fait ce sont des personnes
aux techniques en fait ce sont juste les
voix qui donc
qui prononce la condamnation ce sont des
gens qui pendant le tribunal peuvent
appeler quelqu'un pour demander si telle
ou telle condamnation est donc elle est
bonne le système le système de justice
un biélorussie est absente ce sont tout
simplement des gens qui émettent des
robes noires mais vous pouvez aussi bien
mettre une robe noire pour halloween
pour se déguiser ou ça ne ferait pas de
vous un juge et donc c'est en fait il
n'y a pas de système de justice en
russie en biélorussie
donc le pourcentage
des donc des décisions qui innocentent
la personne c'est
0,0 quelque chose à lui
est en fête s'est expliquée par une
préparation par par une bonne
préparation avant tribunal c'est à dire
que dans le tribunal ne se retrouve que
des gens qui sont
donc
qu'ils sont coupables alors je ne sais
pas quelle est donc calé ce pourcentage
en france mais quelque chose me dit
qu'elle doit être un peu plus élevé
qu'en russie
est ce que vous avez peur du doubs vite
choc
idiote est ce que vous avez peur que
vous mettez du novice choc dans le slip
[Musique]
non parce que je crois que je ne suis
pas une personne aussi importante pour
démarrer tout une opération spéciale
pour moi peut-être que après cette
interview je deviendrai célèbre
donc je devrais avoir peur du nunchuk
mais jusqu'aujourd'hui ah non je n'avais
pas peur faut arrêter de mettre des
slips comme ça ils peuvent pas vous
mettre de nos vies de choc dedans c'est
une blague question internet de assad
titre de l'interview de ce soir vivre en
dictature point d'interrogation en
réaction à cela dans quel système
politique sacha filipenko aimerait-il
vivre quelles innovations en termes de
gouvernance souhaiterait-il voir émerger
au sein de son pays ou 21e siècle
je crois que je ne voudrais pas je ne
voudrais rien de spécial je voudrais
vivre dans un pays où le tribunal font
que les tribunaux fonctionnent où elles
existent le journalisme indépendant
bon après on peut on peut commencer
cette discussion
est ce que ça existe le journalisme
indépendant ou non je voudrais vivre
dans un pays où il existe au moins
plusieurs sources d'opinion et les
attelles journal tel autre journal il ya
une télévision donc de la société je
voudrais vivre plus télévision publique
un bios la russie ne connaissons très
bien le nom du dictateur qui donc qui
nous dirige depuis plusieurs années je
voudrais vivre dans un pays où on n'est
pas obligés de connaître le nom du
président parce que ce n'est pas très
très important et je voudrais vivre dans
un pays un peu comme la suisse ou les
questions importantes pour la population
donc seraient traitées par les
référendums et il je voudrais aussi
vivre dans une culture - atomisé où les
gens sont prêtes à donc
apercevoir
une autre pignon parce que nous vivons
aujourd'hui dans une société où il n'y a
pas de débat où les gens ne sont pas
prêts à considérer un autre point de vue
dans notre pays aussi je crois que notre
président n'a participé qu'une fois au
débat et c'était en
1994 donc allé à presque 30 ans je
voudrais vivre dans un pays où des
normes élémentaires sont respectées je
ne voudrais rien de spécial et si quand
on se trouve en france on te demande
donc est ce que tu es de gauche aux
côtés de droite en amérique on te
demander si tu es libéral le
conservateur nous on vit dans un pays où
ne sait pas que nous sommes on vit dans
un pays où il n'y a pas de réunion
politique dans notre pays tu ne peux pas
dire si tu es de droite ou de gauche
parce qu'il n'ya pas de partis de droite
et il n'ya pas de partis de gauche il ya
juste des partis qui soutiennent le
pouvoir est dans ce sens là je voudrais
commencer une vie politique pour que je
puisse discuter de la politique
dans un café
donc par exemple discuter des élections
de l'importance des migrants parce que
là maintenant pour savoir qui je suis je
dois me mettre sur internet et faire un
test ou en répondant aux questions je
vais comprendre quelles sont mes
opinions politiques
parce que pendant toute ma vie je ne m'a
jamais donné la chance de comprendre
quelles sont tes d'akale parti je
pouvais choisir pense que c'était soit
l'opposition soit le dictateur c'est
tout je crois que je voudrais vivre dans
un pays tout simple question internet
est-ce que sacha et break la biélorussie
post eu pour l'otan et l'union
européenne
yann non je voudrais que ce ne soit pas
sacha qui décide de cela je voudrais que
ce soit les biélorusses qui décide de
cela par un référendum où on ne poserai
ces questions je voudrais qu'on commence
à discuter de cette question aujourd'hui
cette question est très loin de moi
parce que aujourd'hui mon envie c'est de
voir mes amis sortir de prison
aujourd'hui nous essayons donc de
résoudre les problèmes de de tout autre
niveau le fait que nos amis sont
torturés que quatre cent mille personnes
ne sont partis du pays que moi je ne
peux pas retourner dans ma patrie que
mon livre est interdite le spectacle
d'après mon livre il est interdit je ne
peux pas à vendre mon livre dans mon
propre pays je ne peux pas retourner à
la maison donc du coup votre question il
n'est pas très actuel pour notre pays je
voudrais bien me retrouver dans un pays
où il y eut un référendum pour décider
si on veut on veut pas en biélorussie
entré dans le temps et dans l'union
européenne aujourd'hui pour l'instant
c'est cette situation n'est pas
imaginable mais de toute façon je serai
heureux donc je serais content de
n'importe quel choix d'aimer le russe je
serais content de pouvoir en discuter de
pouvoir choisir quelque chose est ce
qu'on a besoin de faire partie de
l'union européenne
on aujourd'hui malheureusement donc nous
sommes très loin d'eux
de cette question ce n'est pas quelque
chose qu'on puisse dont on puisse
décider maintenant est ce que vous
pouvez me dire quelques bonnes choses
qui en biélorussie est quelque peu de
choses qui en russie
yannick euros par combiné
je ne voudrais rien dire de mauvais
contre la russie au contre la
biélorussie ce sont des pays magnifique
que j'aime beaucoup mais que se sont
retrouvés dans une situation tellement
difficile
la biélorussie est un pays magnifique je
voudrais que tout le monde et viennent
que tout le monde des voyages
c'est un pays où donc où il ya les eaux
les garçons le meilleur sens de l'humour
du monde les gars se parle littérature à
effet de serre en france
moi je dis peut-être un il ya beaucoup
de choses et je voudrais que
mon goût parce que je peux parler
beaucoup je peux dire beaucoup de bonnes
choses sur mon pays c'est un pays très
beau très intéressant nous avons des
des histoires fascinantes je pourrais
parler d'eux mêmes façons de la russie
la russie malheureusement pendant toute
son histoire
se retrouve un pays avec une mauvaise
réputation un pays agresseur un pays qui
n'a jamais connu sa voie de rédemption
mais ça n'annule pas le fait que je
connais des gens tout à fait magnifique
à l'intérieur de la russie ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est qu'il n'y a pas une
seule russie il ya plusieurs pays le
tatarstan c'est un pays la tchétchénie
un autre l'oral moscou et saint
pétersbourg autant de pays différents
dans lesquels est très intéressant de
voyager et j'espère un jour la russie va
se dissoudre en plusieurs pays
différents et d'ailleurs ça c'est un
donc ça c'est un article pénale je viens
de proférer quelque chose pour lequel je
risque quelques années de prison en
russie on ne peut pas dire que la russie
puisse se dissoudre si tu en parles tu
risques de te retrouver en prison et
donc moi je crois qu'un jour elle a
réussi va se dissoudre un plusieurs pays
très intéressant avec des gens
magnifiques qui se te prends de la vie
de leur propre pays au lieu d'intervenir
dans la vie des gens
[Musique]
en ce moment il ya de la russophobie on
interdit les chars russes de compétition
internationale
voit une russophobie des bars qui
est ce que vous avez un mot à dire là
dessus
tir de mange ta de camiers je crois que
c'est de la comédie parce que les gens
essaient de
montrer leur solidarité et ça va
jusqu'au ridicule
aujourd'hui par exemple
la société r'n'b nba a interdit aux
biélorusses et 2 les appartements et
c'est vraiment ridicule parce qu'il ya
deux ans encore les européens étaient
solidaires avec la bulle russie il
disait que l'habile russie comme athée
la dictature et aujourd'hui les
biélorusses partent pour combattre donc
un ukraine 2 du côté de le creux de
l'ukraine à les biélorusses ne cesse de
saboter les rails donc des chemins de
fer il a eu plus de 80 cas de sabotage
et quand même elles sont très ils sont
traités des complices de l'agresseur et
la société r'n'b fait un geste et ai dit
qu'elle ne va pas à jouer les
appartements aux biélorusses et je crois
que c'est de la comédie comme avec les
chats comme avec l'interdiction de lire
de style ce qui je crois que les gens
certains j'en veux surtout montré qu'il
est de l'ukraine au lieu de vraiment
aidé le cren
aujourd'hui donc je communique avec une
jeune fille qui
qui s'occupent à acheter des vêtements
de protection des équipements de
protection pour les soldats ukrainien
donc elle envoie les équipements de
l'europe vers le cren parce que
plusieurs soldats ukrainienne
jusqu'aujourd'hui donc avons au combat
soit disant tenue et donc quand je
demande à ces deux jeunes filles si
c'est donc qu'est ce qui est important
pour elle de d'illuminer donc la tour et
c'est l'enjeu des jaunes ou de fermer le
ciel sur le cren bien sûr que pour elle
c'est plus donc c'est plus important
qu'on ferme le ciel mais je vois que
plusieurs européens sont prêtes à donc à
rendre la tour eiffel où les la porte de
brandebourg bleu et jaune voilà mais il
faut quand même hein c'est très bien de
le faire voilà je mets fermé fermer le
ciel c'est bien sûr plus important
envoyé les armes et c'est le plus
important zielinski dit dans chaque
interview il parle des choses qui
manquent à l'ukraine et à chaque fois ce
sont les choses que l'europe ne donne
pas le cren et donc quand on parle de
cette annulation de l'exposition des
chats c'est peut-être un geste fort mais
il ne va pas arrêter poutine je crois
qu'il ya d'autres moyens d'aider
l'ukraine et les chats et ils attendront
le moment donc
on verra on verra pour les chats un
autre moment mais pauvre petit chou
du côté russe la propagande russe la
voix officielle de moscou
on a de l'information qui dit la cia
fait les révolutions de couleur la cia à
envoyer des instructeurs depuis très
longtemps en ukraine la cia a aidé à
former le bataillon azoff
donc c'est vrai c'est pas vrai et est ce
que le fait d'avoir fait ça ça sert pas
la russie pour les en veillant
envoyé des agents
dans le bataillon aof on peut les ouïes
des formules
le jour où cela se passe et personne ne
m'en a parlé et personne n'a demandé mon
conseil donc je n'ai pas vraiment
d'informations sur cela je sais que j'ai
lu l'interview
dans des leaders de bataillon azoff qui
disait que pendant la guerre de
yougoslavie
ils allaient faire la guerre du côté
serbe et pour moi c'est
donc c'est tout à fait
donc fantastique les gens qui étaient
prêtes à combattre le mot de russe donc
pour le mot de russe et en serbie
aujourd'hui donc qu'ils sont contre la
serbie et donc je vois que ce sont des
gens assez compliqué je ne sais pas donc
je ne sais pas trop pourquoi elles font
la guerre aujourd'hui ils font la guerre
pour l'ukraine mais à un moment il était
prête à faire pour la serbie du côté
serbe et il faut dire que la propagande
russe et la tendance d'utiliser tout ce
qui vient à sa portée et donc commenter
ce que dit la propagande de rue ce n'est
pas vraiment important nous avons en
fait très simple il ya un pays
surtout pour qu'on danse pour combattre
cette propagande et il faut avoir les
mêmes instruments et aujourd'hui c'est
assez difficile parce que à l'intérieur
de la russie
ce n'est pas assez ce dont on parle
aujourd'hui
donc ici il y a des gens en france
peut-être en belgique peut-être en
suisse que le verrons dans le monde
francophone mais notre conversation
aujourd'hui personne ne la verra on a
réussi et toute cette discussion le
spectateur russe ne donc ne le verrez
pas ils ne vont pas y penser dit heureux
de te casser importent très peu
je serais très content
c'est la majorité des russes aux
francophones
regardez cette interview
on va parler de trucs plus cool que même
nom
je vais je vais mettre cette vidéo donc
sur ma page donc il y aura des ruches
que l'aveyron
vient vous rue ce que j'adore
c'est à paul
d'un ça veut dire que la police nous a
prévenu samedi les touch cruise c'est un
bon envers été très triste c'est un mot
qui veut dire que la personne ne
commence à boire ne peut pas s'arrêter
et en tant que fils d'un père qui
souvent avait des appeaux je peux vous
dire que c'est très très triste parce
que c'est un moment où ton père ne te
reconnais plus tu peux venir d'une autre
ville pour voir ton papa est donc ton
papa bois depuis des semaines et il ne
comprend pas que c'est toi qui veut bien
le voir il te prends pour un fantôme
donc personnellement pour moi c'est un
mot très triste il n'y a rien de
rien deux guerres ayant d'autres ayant
dans ce mot
les enfants
pour les enfants peut être c'est marrant
d'observer les gens ivres mais en fait
en réalité c'est
ah c'est assez effrayant on a un show
humoristique en france qui a repris ce
mot
faudrait l'enlever il faudrait le
retirer il faudra le compléter il faudra
le changer
je suis pour donc pour faire des blagues
faire les blagues de tous et je suis
absolument convaincu je ne cesse de
faire les blagues sur ma situation sur
mon père mes propres donc mes propres
émotions parce que pour moi le muhr
c'est une sorte de gilet pare-balles
gels et d'amour si donc ici je ne riais
pas de moi même quand on compte ne rit
pas de soi mais non on commence à se
prendre au sérieux on commence à vivre
les tragédies avec beaucoup d'émotion
enfin très très fort tout simplement
pour moi ce mot n'est pas été ridicule
mais c'est un annuler en rien
le fait que je suis convaincu qu'il faut
faire beaucoup de blagues qu'il faut
rire beaucoup rire du tout et même de
mes tragédie personnelle parce que le
rire ne te fait que plus fort
toujours le dire avec humour qui est ce
qu'ils disent est ce type oscar wilde
je crois que c'est c'est la seule chose
qui peut se sauver au sein d'une
dictature
j'ai fait de l'humour j'avais écrit des
sketches pour la première chaîne de la
télé russe qui était censuré
quand on faisait donc je faisais
beaucoup de moore
à la station dost voilà on peut aller à
sasha cohen je posais gens les rues des
questions
je posais des questions tout à fait
l'idiote donc je faisais à peu près la
même chose sur la chaîne d'or et à
travers deux à travers l'humour on peut
montrer souvent une catastrophe
politique dans laquelle se trouve ton
pays à travers l'humour je peux montrer
à quel point aujourd'hui c'est difficile
pour un parti libéral pour n'importe
quel parti démocratique de gagner les
élections parce que les gens ne
comprennent pas du tout de quoi elle
parle et les gens sont prêtes à tout
dire devant les caméras sont prêtes à
dire n'importe quelle bêtise jeu devant
les caméras et dans ce sens là je crois
que le mourre c'est donc ces landais
l'une des bouées de sauvetage donc
la dernière bouée de sauvetage dans la
dictature sans le moore serait était
très très dure et c'est pour ça que
c'est lens qui est aussi cool c'est
parce que lui donc pour lui enfin il a
un très bon sens de l'humour vous êtes
peut-être le prochain président de la
biélorussie
yannis tafer à
mousson
est ce que vous avez en tête à tête on
va demander notre ingénieur joan baez à
l'abattement ses revenus
non non et non est ce que vous avez
envie d'aborder un sujet en particulier
non
il ya deux minutes y'a de mouches tôt et
s'extirpe tac nos gars et mais moi
j'aime bien les deux cherchent un
bastion pour les parler on pourrait
parler de tous disent ici
peut-être je voudrais
comme j'ai la chance
donc de ne pas être la voix de la russie
mais quand même parler un peu de la bile
russie je donne beaucoup d'interviews et
je comprends que plusieurs journalistes
comme donc ils viennnent entrevues et
ils ne comprennent jusqu'aujourd'hui où
se trouvait la biélorussie ils ne
comprennent toujours pas ce que c'est
qu'un pays et quand vous lisez les donc
dans les journaux les
les choses sur la ville il réussit je
voudrais dire aux gens que la bélarussie
ces procès très proche c'est donc à ces
deux heures un avion même si les avions
aujourd'hui donc on a pu vous pouvez
venir un biélorussie en voiture vont
traverser l'allemagne la pologne et vous
êtes un biélorussie nous ne sommes pas
un pylône terre nous sommes parties de
l'europe j'ai toujours je me suis
toujours ressentiez comme européen et
quand vous les et des atrocités qui se
passe un but le russie en ukraine il
faut que vous vous rendiez compte et que
ça ne se passe pas quelque part dans des
contrées lointaines mais ça se passe
donc à au centre de l'europe et donc si
aujourd'hui c'était possibilité d'en
parler je voudrais appeler tout le monde
a à connaître mieux la biélorussie à
lire les livres des auteurs biélorusse
est donc à comprendre que nous sommes
beaucoup plus proches que ça ne paraît
est-ce que vous avez trois livres a
conseillé à d'autres communautés
comme y avoir fait ses classes au
bistrot technique justement il y a trois
de mes livres qui sont parus en france
et ce sont les trois libre que je
conseille de lire ses coûts le titre a
fini 4e où se situe le livre qui vient
de paraître
avec lequel je suis arrivé bon je
comprends que ce n'est pas de la
modestie de ne parler que de moi mais
c'est vous qui me poser cette question
donc le livre qui s'appelle le fils
perdu et ça parle justement de la
bélarussie ça parle de la raison pour
laquelle elle est allée manifester sa
part lieu du coma dans lequel se trouve
tout le pays et ça parle aussi de la
raison pour laquelle je suis devenu un
ancien fils avec ce fils de mon patrie
pourquoi nous partons de notre pays
pourquoi ce pays exil ses meilleurs
enfants et ne laisse que les enfants
fidèles c'est un livre qui dit qu'il y a
des gens qui se réveille après en commun
de 10 ans avec la russie ils comprennent
que rien n'a changé
c'est peut-être le meilleur pays pour
rester dans le coma deux dents parce que
dans ce pays rien ne change jamais
ensuite il ya un autre livre qui
s'appelle la croix rouge qui parle des
atrocités qui se sont produites en
russie
d'enfin au 20e siècle et donc si vous
voulez voir comment les réussis et allez
donc jusqu'au point où elle est
maintenant je croyais que ce serait
utile de lire ce livre il ya beaucoup de
documents beaucoup de matériaux darchy
matériel d'archivés quand vous vous
posez la question pourquoi et comment es
possible ce qui se passe en ukraine
aujourd'hui je crois que ce livre vous
montre justement pourquoi c'est possible
et un troisième livre que qui s'appelle
la traque qui parle de la pression sur
les sur les journalistes donc de la
censure de la destruction des
journalistes et des mécanismes de la
pression sur les journalistes
indépendants donc pour moi c'est une
c'est aussi une bonne excursions 1
réussit un bel russie pour comprendre à
quel point les choses sont faits de
manière atroce de temps en temps
trois autres livres mais pas de joux
hockey
lorsque je n'écris le droit dans
quelques salles
les écrivains du monde où les écrivains
russophone
est bien le russe moi je considérais
jonathan littell les bienveillantes
parce que j'aime bien ce vraiment des
livres qui ont conduit pour vous
catastrophe ne veut plus notamment c'est
une question difficile
parce que j'ai étudié les dates
françaises à lui à la fac et c'est une
question vraiment difficile parce que il
y a donc une très grande quantité de ces
livres
et donc j'ai étudié la littérature non
pas parce que je suis là devant vous
mais en fait céline et proust sont très
importants pour moi
les livres de perec sont également un
très important
m donc le livre de route n aussi
les billets les bienveillantes de little
également parce que ayant lu ce livre
j'ai voulu écrire un roman historique où
je pourrais parler de mon propre pays
donc le coût de la côte des syrtes aussi
enfin il y a
beaucoup de livres et vous ne pourrez
pas m'arrêter parce que je le
souhaiterais sans arrêt
est-ce que vous avez un conseil pour les
jeunes générations une bouteille à la
mer quelque chose d'impérissables qu'on
va laisser sur les réseaux vous et moi
ne jamais à côté de conseils
toujours offert que c'était tout
simplement
parce qu'ils sont le meilleur ils sont
présentés les gens que nous nous avons
un
un ressentiment contre les générations
suivantes
mais ils savent beaucoup mieux ce qu'il
veut ce qu'il faut faire sans nos
conseils
la commune ratissent sont en train de
marquer des passages de vote y voilà
c'est bien il suffire de vous les gars
et les filles
on arrive à la fin de notre interview on
vous remercie d'être venu nous voir et
on va se voir une bien
sale à voir avec
sa chère à philippe et commercy mais
c'est à vous
[Musique]
dans
e